un visado que será más caro y más
difícil de obtener esa es la nueva
realidad para los ciudadanos rusos que
quieran entrar en la unión europea los
ministros de asuntos exteriores de los
27 estados miembros acordaron el
miércoles en fraga poner fin al régimen
de visa relajada para los rusos vigente
desde 2007
esto significa que se reducirá
significativamente el número de nuevas
visas expedidas por los estados miembros
de la unión europea mandar stage
el proceso será más difícil y más largo
y por consiguiente el número de nuevas
visas se verán sustancialmente reducida
y sustanciales de dios'
será una suspensión del régimen actual
pero no una prohibición total de visados
para todos los rusos como pedían polonia
y los tres países bálticos sólo se
seguirá impidiendo viajar a europa a los
allegados al kremlin objetivo desde el
inicio de la guerra en ucrania para
algunos estas nuevas medidas no son
suficientes
no se trata de un castigo se trata
básicamente de plantearse la cuestión de
si el derecho a pasar un tiempo de ocio
en la unión europea es un derecho humano
y no lo creo es un privilegio y los
países suelen tener que ganarse este
tipo de privilegios
junto a lituania polonia letonia y
estonia están considerando la
posibilidad de prohibir completamente el
paso de rusos por sus fronteras pero
varios países sobre todo alemania han
argumentado que una prohibición total
penalizaría a los disidentes y a todos
los rusos que quieran huir de su país
más de un millón de ciudadanos rusos han
entrado en la unión europea desde el
inicio de la invasión en ucrania la
mayoría de ellos a través de finlandia y
estonia